OF THE CONFLICT IN UKRAINE TO
TAKE THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> Reporter: THIS WAS THE MOMENT
ON THE FIRST DAY OF THIS WAR.
RUSSIA'S PLAN FOR A LIGHTNING
STRIKE STARTED TO UNRAVEL.
WE WITNESSED THESE LIGHTLY ARMED
RUSSIAN AIRBORNE TROOPS FIGHTING
FOR THEIR LIVES ON THE OUTSKIRTS
OF KYIV.
NOW THE UKRAINIAN DEFENSE
MINISTER TELLS CNN WRITTEN
MILITARY ORDERS WERE RECOVERED
FROM THE BODY OF A RUSSIAN
OFFICER KILLED HERE CONFIRMING
HIS RUSSIAN COMMANDERS EXPECTED
A QUICK ATTACK.
>> HE HAD TO BE IN GOVERNMENT
QUARTER AFTER 12 HOURS FROM THE
INVASION, FROM THE STARTING OF
THE INVASION.
>> CENTER OF KYIV.
HE HAD TO CONTROL BUILDING,
OFFICE OF PRESIDENT, PARLIAMEN.
AND 72 HOURS AFTER THEY WERE
SURE THAT, FOR EXAMPLE,
PRESIDENT WILL BE EVACUATED --
>> Reporter: IN RETROSPECT, THAT
LOOKS ASTONINGLY NAIVE, DID YOU
WANT IT.
>> FRANKLY, OUR PARTNERS WERE
ALSO NAIVE.
THEY ALSO TOLD US THAT INVASION
ARE IMMINENT AND THEY WILL FALL.
YOU HAVE ONLY 72 HOURS.
>> Reporter: BUT THEN FOUR
MONTHS NOW, UKRAINE HAS BEEN
HOLDING OUT, EVEN DEFEATING
RUSSIAN FORCES NEAR THE CAPITAL
WITH THE HELP OF ARMOR-PIERCING
WEAPONS FROM THE U.S. AND
OTHERS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALREADY COMMITTED TO $40 BILLION
TO THIS FIGHT, AND THE UKRAINIAN
DEFENSE MINISTER INSISTS THAT
WASHINGTON AND ITS ALLIES HAVE
ASSURED HIM THAT SUPPORT WILL
CONTINUE.
>> OUR PARTNERS WILL NEVER STOP.
I WAS TOLD THAT.
I SPOKE WITH MY FRIEND AUSTIN --
LLOYD AUSTIN, SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE OF THE UNITED STATES,
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE OF UK, BEN
WALLACE, AND OUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES.
THEY TOLD ME, ALEXI, DON'T
WORRY.
WE WILL NOT STOP.
>> Reporter: DO YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS A GENUINE
COMMITMENT BY THE UNITED STATES
TO CONTINUE TO MILITARILY BACK
UKRAINE INTO THE FUTURE NO
MATTER WHAT?
>> I HEARD YESTERDAY AND I FELT
THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY HONESTLY.
>> Reporter: AND THE UKRAINIANS
ARE HONEST TOO ABOUT WHAT THEIR
NEW WEAPONS WILL BE FOR, WEAPONS
LIKE THESE STATE OF THE ART
INTEGRAL 7 GUNS THAT WE WERE
SHOWN IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE
EARLIER THIS MONTH, OR THE
MULTIPLE LAUNCH ROCKET LAUNCHERS
THAT WILL SOON BE IN SERVICE
HERE.
THE DEFENSE MINISTER SAYS THEY
WILL HELP UKRAINE TAKE BACK
OCCUPIED LAND.
>> WE ARE GOING TO LIBERATE ALL
OUR TERRITORIES.
>> ALL OF IT.
>> WHAT ABOUT CRIMEA.
>> CRIMEA IS UKRAINIAN.
FOR ME, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTANDABLE.
>> SO, YOU'RE SAYING THAT CRIMEA
IS A MILITARY OBJECTIVE OF THE
UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES WITH THIS
WEAPON?
>> I ASSURE THAT CRIMEA IS A
STRATEGIC OBJECTIVE FOR UKRAINE
BECAUSE IT'S A UKRAINIAN
TERRITORY.
BUT WE WILL MOVE STEP BY STEP.
I MEAN, THE FIRST STAGE, IT'S
STABILIZATION.
>> Reporter: THE REASON I ASK --
>> I WILL FINISH MY -- THE
SECOND STAGE IS TO KEEP THEM
OUT, FILL THE 24 FEBRUARY BORDER
SITUATION.
AND THIRD STAGE, WE WILL DISCUSS
IT WITH OUR PARTNERS HOW WE'LL
LIBERATE OUR TERRITORIES,
INCLUDES CRIMEA ALSO.
>> Reporter: NONE OF THAT WILL
GO DOWN WELL IN MOSCOW.
AND EVEN WITH ADVANCED WESTERN
WEAPONS TO R